CD Projekt RED is pretty much  inseparable from the witcher series but  the team is hard at work on their next  big open world game cyberpunk 2077 and  apparently it's even bigger and scale  than gerelds adventures I'm Tony and  this game spot news update comes  straight from night city the witcher 3  raised the bar for open-world RPG s so  studio head Adam Badowski says cyberpunk  will have to be quote even better even  bigger and even more revolutionary it's  a long way from launch but Badowski says  it's already a huge game with a much  greater magnitude than the witcher  series the studio will also be hiring  plenty of new developers to match its  ambition cyberpunk is scheduled to  release sometime between 2017 and 20 21  that's less of a release window and more  of a giant release glass wall but I  guess that makes sense given what CD  Projekt RED is hoping to achieve with  this game in the meantime stay tuned to  gamespot for all the latest on cyberpunk  2077  you